Hello, hello, everyone!
Pre-recorded Doki is back!
Haha, that's me!
Today, I am sponsored by Sega and Sonic the Hedgehog to check out Sonic Racing Crossworld!
It's currently available now on PC and all major platforms.
You can check it out right now and play with your friends!
It'll mean a lot, Dragons!
If you can click on the link in the description below and maybe get the game today!
Huge shoutout and thank you to the devs for reaching out tried a new racing game.
Alright, it's time to come out of racing retirement and win the Grand Prix.
One last job.
It's time, pre-recorded Doki.
I believe in you.
You don't need chat to hold your racing wheel and back to you.
Take it away, pre-recorded Doki number two.
Thanks, pre-recorded Doki.
Hello, everybody.
It's also pre-recorded Doki here.
Yes, I am so excited to try out Sonic Racing Crossworlds.
Do you remember when I first saw the trailer for this game?
I was like, Miku Hatsune and Steve?
So for those who don't know, the DLC characters that you can get for Sonic Racing Crossworld, there's Steve, there's Avatar, there's Pac-Man, and Teenage Moon and Ninja Turtles, and also SpongeBob.
The thing is, there's also free characters.
So in the
I'm like, oh my god, this is like the greatest crossover in history.
Oh my god, Sonic and Friends.
And look, oh my god, and oh my god, there's a lot of cars.
Oh my gosh, this song's a banger.
I think that's what I love about Sonic, too.
Like, they have some really good songs.
Is that even legal?
Why don't I just play Shadow?
I can literally play as a monster truck and just, he just destroyed his car.
Why wouldn't I play as Shadow?
Yeah.
All right, okay, we definitely need the tutorial because I don't know how to play.
Guess it's time to get into the race.
I don't, oh, okay, I'm one player because I'm by myself, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Who needs friends when I can win, you know?
Oh my god, there's Igman's child.
I forgot his name.
Her name.
Yeah, okay, I gotta be Shadow.
I love Latinas.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I know, like, this is a Sonic game and I should play the main character, but they have.
shadow.
Okay, where's the monster truck?
I could just bring like the skateboards over.
I'm gonna get that one.
Wait, normal rate.
Wait, quick charge.
I feel like double boost seems the best.
It gives you an advantage in general.
Round one, E Stadium.
Oh, that's like the first world.
I love the original Sonic world, like the level one Sonic world.
It's so cute.
That's me.
That's right.
The main guys i'm trying to remember how to do okay it's it's left click it's rb lb got my drift that's right oh my god look at all these air tricks that i'm doing naturally guys oh my god i'm gaming okay i don't do this is that does that hit her oh it's like a oh it does an auto aim can you handle this i'm literally first place what do you mean oh i'm at the casino let's go gambling bomb.
Wait, did I use it on my... No, no, okay, I just bumped into this fight.
Oh, my God, there's so many things going on.
It's so fast.
Oh, I'm so close.
I just need one item.
I just literally need one item to rule them off.
Oh, I need to be close to her.
Oh, I didn't know.
No!
It's okay.
I still have the other races.
It's fine.
It's just a warm-up, guys.
It's a No!
Down is up!
I know they just taught me that!
Alright, I have another boost though.
What?
Red!
They don't care!
License clean!
Oh my gosh, she took away all my coins too.
She literally robbed me in the middle of it.
Random track.
Oh, it transports me to a different track!
Oh, oh, no, no, don't hit me, don't hit me, don't hit me!
Don't hit me!
No!
No, my God!
guy who let him bring a weapon again I just got here oh so I got it I got ran over and I got ran over by a truck kid had nothing apparently that's right and now I'm back in the country the city was rough on me guys it was so rough that's right first place baby I told you that was just a warm-up game.
I like how Eggman's last.
I like how his child beat him, too.
Oh, dragon looks.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
We're literally in a dragon.
That's fine.
Oh, no, that's not fine.
That's not fine.
I still have a lot.
I still have a lot of coins, though.
I still have a lot of coins.
Alright, we're boosting.
We're boosting.
The salvage wolf.
We can We just salvage it.
We can salvage it.
Oh no!
No!
We're all so close to each other!
We're all so close.
Please.
Please!
Please let me swim again!
Second!
Yes!
Oh, there!
Oh my god!
This is the thing that got first place.
I know it's crying.
Here's the guy you made fun of in high school.
Oh, this is the final lap.
Come on.
I literally just need a win.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
All right.
Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
First place!
That's right!
Prime Papi's still.
Oh, my God.
You don't even get second in your face, girl.
Where's your original spinoff game?
That's right.
You don't got any.
I don't even know.
Wait, her name's rave.
Okay, I know her name.
customize your own machine by combining front party rear parts and tires oh yeah I heard like there's like you customize your vehicles a lot in both looks and also like the performance like if you think like where is it is this oh here okay power oh so I can oh my god I was on a dragon okay that was fitting I didn't even realize it was called dragon oh and I could customize the paint job too uh oh my god there's so many things there's so many options to do okay fight me all right now i have a actual dragon car now oh yeah by the way guys there is cross play for this game so you can play against any your friends on any platform so they have like if they have sonic racing on console and you're on you know you're on steam you can actually play with your friends so i think that's that's really good i always love that team sonic this one is where i have to like hit them and stuff it's like bumper cars oh i can randomize the mansion.
Wait, I want to try.
It's almost Halloween.
I want to try that.
Cream, why are you on the enemy team?
Oh my god, I really, I already forgot the objective.
And it was, it was the bump into them.
And I didn't do any of that.
It's okay.
My team is second place.
And there's two.
It's only two teams.
And my team is, oh, doing, oh, that's the monster truck.
That's a power-up.
Oh, that's sick.
I didn't realize that was a Power up.
Okay, I got another monster truck.
Oh.
Okay.
Not gonna lie, I thought the monster truck was auto.
That's my bad.
That's okay.
I did it.
This is a team effort.
And we did it together as a team, guys.
Okay.
Nice.
Thank God they were all in front of you.
me too that was a good use of my tornadoes no no it's fine no it's not fun no i believe i believe ruse please ruse you're our only hope please no
it's not my fault i got it There's no way we have second third and fourth.
It should balance out right this should balance out right Wait, is that it?
No,
I swear to god
No, no change, but I don't need baby mode Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Are you serious?
I don't even know wait wait wait wait first I'm first I'm first Okay, okay, I got first.
Okay, I just need I'm I got sickened!
What?
Oh no!
Eggpot!
You screw up the world!
Now we're gonna lose!
Are you serious, Eggpot?
You just couldn't let me...
My team win!
It's not even my fault!
Guys, in the end, I knew it.
I just had to be a solo.
Never, never rely on your teammates, guys.
No, not me!
Not me!
What?!
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize I didn't hit myself!
I died!
Oh my god, I actually...
Oh no!
I'm groovy!
You know what I love about this item?
There's no cliff.
Thank god.
That's the best pie.
Okay.
No!
Yes!
Oh my god.
That's right.
You try to aim for the king.
Oh my god.
Should have aimed for the head.
That's right.
I told you guys.
Don't rely on nobody.
Just believe in yourself.
You don't need no team.
In the end, I won, guys.
With my trusty dragon car.
Again, thank you so much to Sega and Sonic the Hedgehog for sponsoring this video.
available now on PC and all major platforms so you can use the link in the description to get the game today Sonic Racing Crossroads is the definite cart racer experience with cross play compatibility so you can play with all of your friends it doesn't matter what console they're on you can still match up and party with them but yeah if you wish to support the devs and this game please feel free to purchase it right now or click on the link that's pinned in the description so thank you again everyone hope you guys enjoy this video i almost said stream but it's not a stream all right pre-recorded tokyi signing off bye bye everyone bye
wait i could configure it that's good oh all right searing assist auto acceleration and trick
No, no, they don't, they won't.
They'll never know.
No, no.